breaking news overnight the January 6
committee released its final report it
finds a quote the central cause of
January 6 was one man former president
Donald Trump the house select committee
argues that due to his alleged
involvement in the violence on that day
Donald Trump should be barred from
holding office in the future Scott
McFarland is on Capitol Hill with more
on the report Scott good morning to you
hey Gail good morning it's an 845 page
final report which culminates a two-year
investigation with 10 public hearings
one thousand plus interviews and one
million plus documents
[Applause]
the final report is out and it lays out
in explicit detail how Donald Trump
allegedly engaged in a multi-part
conspiracy to overturn the lawful
results of the 2020 presidential
election
inciter to moth
put his vice president's life in danger
and try to subvert the justice
department and local election officials
there's overwhelming and voluminous
evidence that Donald Trump just refused
to take no for an answer from the
American people the panel issued 11
recommendations in the report to help
prevent future attacks including
strengthening enforcement of the 14th
Amendment which bans insurrectionists
from holding public office they argue
that would prevent Trump from running
again it also recommended a more
rigorous oversight in full funding of
Capitol Police
to protect election workers in the
future it recommends protecting their
identities and increasing penalties for
threats made against them and to bolster
its subpoena enforcement power in
response to the Trump allies that
refused to comply one star witness who
did comply was Cassidy Hutchinson the
former Aid of white house chief of staff
Mark Meadows thank you you may be seated
late Thursday the committee released
transcripts of interviews she conducted
in September after the public hearings
this summer
she told the panel Trump insiders
including lawyer Stefan pasentino
pressured her to remain loyal despite
facing a risk of contempt of congress
she said passantino told her to downplay
your role you were a secretary you had
an administrative role and the less you
remember the better it's outrageous and
scandalous and indefensible that there
would be an attempt to interfere with
our investigation by influencing
Witnesses posantino said he acted
honorably ethically and fully consistent
with Hutchinson's sole interests the
panel largely boycotted by House
Republicans received praise from
California Democrat Nancy Pelosi in her
final press conference as U.S House
speaker we have a vital road map
ensuring Justice is will be done and
keep and that this won't happen again
Donald Trump responded to the
investigation and the report calling it
a Witch Hunt and saying it failed to
study the reasons for protests with the
committee now wrapping up its work the
attention shifts David to the justice
department and whether they take
criminal actions against Trump
Scott McFarland at the Capitol this
morning thank you Scott